sur public sénat
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat dans moins de quinze minutes vous
pourrez suivre en direct les
traditionnelles questions d'actualité au
sénat mais en attendant est avec nous
sur ce plateau nous allons parler un
petit peu de toute l'actualité de cette
semaine est de ce jour une évidemment
avec alain vidalis bonjour alain
vidalies 100 jours ministre en charge
des relations avec le parlement est une
question bien entendu aujourd'hui on va
apprendre en fin de journée les chiffres
du chômage 23ème mois consécutif de
hausse
françois hollande lors de son
intervention après le conseil des
ministres
il a parlé du mariage mais il a
également dit stop c'est fini on parle
d'autre chose de l'emploi il serait
temps peut-être de parler de l'emploi la
vie des listes je pense que non
seulement qu'ils seraient tort mais ç'a
toujours été temps je dire la principale
préoccupation des français
c'est la question de l'emploi et c'est
aussi la principale préoccupation du
gouvernement et c'est pour ça que nous
avons commencé dans les premières lois
par traiter à la fois des emplois
d'avenir à la fois du contrat de
génération du pacte de compétitivité
donc il ya eu beaucoup de choses qui ont
été faites sur la question prioritaire
et ça a été fait en priorité
alain vidalies je savais que vous allez
me parler de tout ce qui a été mis en
place alors justement jamais quelques
chiffres notamment sur les emplois
d'avenir et bien on voit bien que ça ne
prend pas tant que ça est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas les ouvrir à des emplois
privés par exemple à des étudiants qui
auraient plus de diplômes par exemple
c'est pas tellement la question de
l'ouverture à des emplois privés qui est
déjà prévue par dérogation par région
dans un certain nombre de branches
c'est plutôt le savoir si on élargit à
d'autres catégories de jeunes que ce
qu'on avait qu'on avait ciblé en même
temps quand on fait la comparaison avec
la montée en puissance des emplois
jeunes on n'est pas spécialement en
retard et donc il faut quand même
aujourd'hui plutôt appeler à la
mobilisation notamment du côté des
collectivités locales du côté des
associations et ne faut pas assez
peut-être qu'on n'a pas réussi à les
convaincre que l'appareil d'état sur le
terrain n'a pas été assez efficace mais
il ya beaucoup de travail qui est fait
elle est surtout la situation comme
toujours un peu et très disparates d'un
département à l'autre ce qui montre bien
que
là où il ya eu une vraie implication et
de l'administration et des élus il ya de
bons résultats et donc finalement c'est
ces résultats-là qui doit servir de
référence
vous êtes vous connaissez certainement
le conseil d'analysé économique qui a
fait une étude qui est proche évidemment
du premier ministre et qui a fait qu'il
faudrait revoir les politiques de
l'emploi en faveur des jeunes donc c'est
exactement ce que vous nous dites
sauf que ce n'est pas mis encore en
place donc quand est ce qu'on va pouvoir
commencer à voir les premiers chiffres
quand est ce que vous imaginez que ce
chômage va pouvoir enfin descendre ce
que le président de la république a dit
c'est que ce que nous avons mis en
oeuvre devrait aboutir à une inversion
de la courbe du chômage à la fin de
l'année senna c'est notre objectif c'est
ça reste notre objectif ça dépend une
politique de l'emploi ces deux choses
c'est premièrement des politiques
spécifiques
on les a mis en oeuvre pour les jeunes
contrat de génération emploi de venir
mais aussi pour les seniors c'est le
contrat c'est le contrat de génération
on a maintenu tout ce qui existe et
notamment sur les contrats de
professionnalisation l'apprentissage et
puis deuxièmement il ya la question de
la croissance
évidemment qu'il ya un lien entre les
deux et les choix qui a été fait et
notamment le cic et c'est quand même pas
rien aujourd'hui tout pour ceux qui
n'ont le cec et c'est ce qui a été mis
avec le pacte de compétitivité c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
entreprises de france mais
malheureusement elles ne savent pas
assez peuvent aller demander une avance
de 4 % de leur masse salariale pour
toutes les entreprises quelle que soit
leur taille les skis quand même permet
de financer les investissements
aujourd'hui donc il faut aussi faire ce
travail on a vraiment aussi le sentiment
que beaucoup des outils qu'on a mis en
place ne sont pas connus ou non pas été
assez expliqué donc c'est à défaut de
communication que vous avouer sont
diverses et pas un défaut de
communication mais à partir du moment où
il y a une méconnaissance des outils
qu'on a mis en place et tous des élus
font cette expérience avec notamment
beaucoup de beaucoup de pme qui ignore
encore qu'il ya cette possibilité qu'on
peut avoir même une avance c'est à dire
de l'argent qui est versé via la banque
publique d'investissement il faut leur
dire il faut leur répéter ces 20 min
ils doivent servir à quelque chose
notamment aux entreprises qui veulent
investir ce conseil économique d'analysé
économique dit aussi par exemple un rsa
à l'âge de 18 ans c'est possible ça c'
est envisagée au gouvernement c'est pas
envisager pour l'instant la proposition
est en discussions mais ça pose d'autres
problèmes
on va parler maintenant un petit peu de
tout et encore une fois de cette
actualité il ya une autre actualité très
forte c'est cette amnistie pour on a
appelé ça les délinquant syndicats pour
ceux en tout cas qui ont été condamnés
pour des actes syndicale sadek el très
fort avec notamment
est-ce que vous pour vous cette amnistie
qui n'aura pas lieu finalement parce que
le gouvernement a dit no on peut
peut-être vous rappeler ce qui a été dit
ici dans l'hémicycle du sénat par
christiane taubira à l'époque lé partait
avait parlé d'un acte de justice
pourquoi est-ce qu'on revient comme ça
deux mois près face tout en février
pourquoi est-ce qu'on revient deux mois
après vous avez raison de préciser que
c'était en février une mesure d'
amnistie c'est une mesure d'apaisement
qui ne peut intervenir que dans une
société qui est apaisé or qui peut
ignorer aujourd'hui il ne l'est pas
aujourd'hui alain vidalies selon elle ne
l'est plus elle ne l'est plus personne
ne peut ignorer ce qui se passe depuis
un certain nombre de semaines
soir après soir pendant plusieurs
semaines encore aujourd'hui il y à des
manifestations il ya des groupes
d'extrême droite qui ont infiltré la
manifestation pour tous qui attaquent
les forces de l'ordre dans le débat à
l'assemblée nationale on a entendu
parler de d'action légitime c'est à dire
que certains revendiquer le fait que
c'était normal parce que leur
contestation était légitime des députés
de droite
je crois que nous nous avons la
responsabilité de la sécurité publique
il ya des grandes manifestations qui
sont annoncés donc ce que dit le
gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
les circonstances ont changé mais c'est
que la loi doit être la même pour tous
et que ce qui nous unit
puisque nous avons la responsabilité de
la sécurité publique c'est le respect de
la loi et qu'il ne faut donner aucun
signe qui pourrait justifier même si
c'est pas la même chose nous nous
soutenons l'action des syndicalistes
nous soutenons l'action des syndicats
mais il faut quand même que ceux qui
sont à l'origine de cette de cette
proposition de loi
comprennent aujourd'hui que les
adversaires d'extrême droite d'attendre
que justement cette circonstance pour
justifier leur propre violence et que le
gouvernement lui il doit défendre les
principes de la république et le
principe de la république c'est le
respect de la loi
tout le temps partout et par tout le
monde je reprends juste sur un poids la
vie d'alice c'était oui en février mais
depuis les débordements après la loi sur
le mariage tout a changé
c'est bien ça si on n'y a pas eu de wii
en février le gouvernement n'a pas dit
oui il a dit ça geste à dire il a dit au
fond la discussion peut se poursuivre et
d'ailleurs
viendra au sénat dans quelque temps mais
le seul message qui est possible
aujourd'hui de la part du gouvernement
ces deux choses premièrement de dire la
loi doit être respectée par tout le
monde et que en ce moment est un message
qui doit être fort parce que c'est la
question des valeurs de la république
qui est contestée par certains
et deuxièmement il y a dans la
revendication de ce qui était à
l'origine de la loi sur l'amnistié un
point qui fait problème sur lequel ils
doivent être entendus
c'est la condamnation d'un syndicaliste
qui avait refusé de se livrer à des
prélèvements de génétique enfin de
salive donc là dessus vous allez là
c'est la loi qui est en elle même qui
peut être réformé c'est pas une question
d' amnistie et donc nous sommes prêts à
examiner cette situation qui résulte de
modifications à la loi qui avait été
fait par la précédente majorité on va
changer un petit peu de sujets vous avez
peut-être lu le monde avec cette
interview de claude bartolone bartolone
le président de l'assemblée nationale
qu'il va pas de main morte claude
bartolone parce qu'il dit tout
simplement qu'il faudrait un deuxième
souffle finalement pour le quinquennat
il dit mais il serait peut-être temps de
parler du social et arrêté un petit peu
le côté sociétale et parler finalement à
vos électeurs
mais ce que je vous ai dit sur ce qu'on
a fait sur la question sociale est quand
même la meilleure des réponses
on a fait beaucoup de choses sur les
questions d'emploi il y a aussi le texte
sur la cci l'appétit mais sur ce que
sécurisation l'emploi oui mais je ne
vois pas de propositions très précises
mais il ya une analyse qui aujourd'hui
est dans le débat comme claude bartolone
fait sur la question européenne sur la
question de la 2de le nouveau ton du
quinquennat je dit explicitement ce qui
fait d'ailleurs il fait pas de
propositions concrètes donc je ne sais
pas comment porter une appréciation mais
dans tous les cas le fait qu'aujourd'hui
ils veuillent réaffirmé qu' on ne pourra
pas finalement évoluer ou s'en sortir
s'il n'ya pas le retour de la croissance
et que donc la question qui est posée
notamment au niveau de l'europe ça
correspond à ce que le président de la
république fait depuis le mois de juin
il ya aujourd'hui un vrai débat dans
laquelle la france doit prendre toute sa
place sur l'avenir de l'europe l'avenir
de l'europe n'est pas dans l'austérité
la loi sur la transparence alain vidalis
n arrive qu à l'assemblée au sénat
elle arrivera à l'assemblée nationale
dans la semaine du 17 juin
mais probablement la première semaine de
juillet ou mi juillet au c'est là alors
on évoque depuis quelques jours j'ai pas
pourquoi cette idée de 49 3 c'est ce
qu'on appelle un peu le vote bloqué tac
vous passeriez en force
écoutez je profite de cette émission
pour démentir ce que j'ai lu ce matin
dans un quotidien national je n'ai
jamais l'a voté je n'ai jamais évoqué
cette question de l'utilisation du 49-3
qui n'est aujourd'hui et n'a jamais été
évoquée ni à l'elysée ni à matignon pour
que les choses se taire c'est clair mais
est-ce que vous aurez cette majorité
parce qu'on sent bien que les députés du
parti socialiste ne sont pas forcément
avec vous d'ailleurs sept en tout cas
d'ailleurs cette loi fera l'aménager non
il faudra là ménagé hier un projet de
loi qui a été adoptée c'est la position
du gouvernement maintenant il va y avoir
des débats avec le parlement d'ailleurs
la majorité et l'opposition puisque sur
la question de la transparence n'est pas
une question qui concerne que les
députés de la majorité et ça concerne
l'ensemble du parlement et je crois que
c'est une question qui est juste
aujourd'hui sauf si beaucoup veulent
s'exonérer de cette situation que je
regrette qui est que au fond la
population doute doute de ses élus et
que même dans les sondages on voit que
beaucoup 80% des gens pensent que la
classe politique est corrompu on sait
quoi que j'ai de bonnes chances de faire
passer cette loi a coûté dans tous les
cas je rentre dans ce combat avec l'idée
que ce que veut le président de la
république sera écoutée et entendue
je crois que cette derrière c'est une
question démocratique c'est que les gens
retrouvent confiance dans leurs dents
les personnes qui les représentent
dernière question il y aura bien un
congrès à versailles demandait
par le gouvernement est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un petit peu plus la
date et quel texte sera abordé lors de
ce congrès réuni à versailles
oui donc ce qui est envisagé aujourd'hui
c'est que y ait un seul des textes de
réforme constitutionnelle
ils soient examinées par le parlement
c'est-à-dire l'assemblée le sénat dans
d'ici la fin le 15 juillet c'est la
réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature ou savez les conditions il
faut que le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale se mettent d'accord sur un
texte identique et connaît la capacité
de réunir les trois cinquièmes au
congrès à versailles
donc il faudra vérifier mais uniquement
sur ce texte les autres ne seront pas
examinés dans l'immédiat sur ce texte si
on a cette majorité si on l'a
le congrès pourrait se dérouler le 22
juillet mais ce sont des décisions qui
relèvent du président de la république
mais c'est la date qui était évoqué
merci beaucoup à la vie d'alice
évidemment regagner le bord des
ministres les questions d'actualité dans
une poignée de minutes et en attendant
un à jade vallaud belkacem la porte
parole du gouvernement est avec no mercy
elle nous fait plaisir de venir sur son
plateau pour commenter
peut-être alain vidalies cela fait tout
à l'heure mais ces chiffres qui vont
tomber en fin de journée sur le chômage
c'est le 23e mois consécutif de hausse
du chômage
qu'est ce qui selon vous pourra
permettre de garantir ce que françois
hollande avait promis c'est à dire la
baisse du chômage d'ici à la fin de
l'année la mise en oeuvre des réformes
que nous avons d'ores et déjà adoptée
pour certaines
ils ont droit d'adoption pour d'autres
on en voit les effets vous savez quand
vous mettez boutabout par exemple les
contrats de génération et puis les
emplois d'avenir c'est quasiment par
jour plus de 500 emplois qui sont
nouvellement fourni et donc ça veut dire
par jour 500 gènes qui trouve enfin une
activité rémunérée tellement ces
derniers chiffres du chômage arriver aux
usa continuent à monter nous qu'on se
pose vraiment des questions à savoir
comment vous allez faire pour pour faire
j'ai gueulé justement cette hausse mais
les chiffres du chômage montrent
pourquoi parce que la croissance est
atone tout simplement mais en même temps
là la façon de procéder du gouvernement
ça a été un volontarisme politique
extrêmement fort pour finalement
j'allais dire faire plier père plié le
sort le sort c'est en effet le chômage
la façon dont nous le faisons plié c'est
que nous incitons les entreprises à
embaucher avec le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi en réduisant la rue
man ce que leur coûterait normalement
leur masse salariale avec les contrats
de génération en permettant à la fois
des jeunes d'entrer sur le marché du
travail et à des seniors d'y rester mais
aussi avec un certain nombre
d'investissements on en parle sans doute
pas assez mais les moyens dégagés par le
gouvernement pour investir par exemple
sur le haut débit sur l'ensemble du
territoire les moyens dégagés par le
gouvernement sur l'hôpital sont aussi
des perspectives d'emploi et voyez
d'autres mesures que nous avons prises
comme par exemple la réduction du taux
de tva dans le secteur du logement va
permettre la construction de logements
et donc des emplois aussi quand
estimez-vous à quelle date si on peut
déjà faire des annonces qu'on va pouvoir
sentir cette baisse dans les chiffres
qui sont fournis aujourd'hui mais nous
ne sommes pas des devins
c'est très difficile de vous répondre
précisément succès on peut vous dire ce
que l'on peut vous dire et ça n'est pas
une question de foi mais une question de
volonté politique
c'est que nous mettons tout en oeuvre
l'ensemble du gouvernement est mobilisé
aujourd'hui quasiment qu'autour d'une
obsession car c'est une obsession c'est
la lutte contre le chômage et donc à
mettre tout en oeuvre l'état mais aussi
les collectivités locales les
associations les entreprises
eh bien ça finira par payer bien entendu
merci beaucoup d'achats de vallaud
belkacem on voulait être gagné
évidemment la séance a commencé bariza
khiari président cette séance de
questions d'actualité à tout à l'heure
risation de l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle puis son opposition
soudaine à l'aministie des salariés en
lutte
pourtant votée par notre assemblée sont
des signes particulièrement négatif en
direction de tous ceux qui n'ont que
leur capacité de travail pour vivre
les chiffres du chômage l'étude de
l'insee sur le pouvoir d'achat sont là
pour confirmer que le mal être des
salariés employés retraités demandeurs
d'emploi dans notre pays n'est pas qu'un
ressenti momentanée le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages est en baisse pour la
première fois depuis 30 ans et frappe
particulièrement les plus pauvres
c'est la première fois insiste line
c'est que nous constatons une
accentuation si importante des
inégalités
ce sont ces populations qui ont le plus
besoin des politiques publiques des
services publics
or vous avez décidé de poursuivre une
politique inscrite dans le pacte de
stabilité européen
que de plus en plus de pays considèrent
comme un carcan contre productif pour
sortir de la crise n'est-il pas temps au
contraire monsieur le ministre de
changer de cap
les forces politiques et populaires qui
ont chassé nicolas sarkozy du pouvoir le
6 mai 2012 ne se retrouve pas dans la
politique aujourd'hui menée il est donc
urgent d'envoyer des signes forts sur
les libertés syndicales sur l'emploi le
pouvoir d'achat et ainsi redonner le
goût de la victoire à celles et ceux qui
l'ont voulu
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
agir au nom de la france en europe pour
définir une autre politique économique
budgétaire république qui retrouvera les
voies de la croissance et donc de la
réduction des déficits par une dépense
publique nouvelles efficaces par une
plus grande justice fiscale mettant un
terme aux cadeaux indécent car accordés
aux plus riches et aux entreprises les
plus profitables par une mobilisation
constante des forces de changement
merci madame beaufils
la parole est un monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre du budget madame la
sénatrice merci infiniment pour votre
question qui pose un certain nombre de
problèmes dans lequel moi même je me
retrouve la nécessité d'avoir une
politique économique qui rendent
possible la synthèse entre le
rétablissement des comptes publics
et le retour de la croissance une
politique économique et budgétaire qui
ne perdent pas de vue l'objectif de la
justice sociale une politique économique
et budgétaire par les orientations
qu'elle définit qui porte une ambition
de politique industrielle qui permettent
de lutter efficacement contre le chômage
le premier point sur lequel je voudrais
insister en réponse à votre question
c'est que il n'est pas imputable à
l'europe
de devoir aujourd'hui rétablir nos
comptes publics ce n'est pas de la
responsabilité de l'europe
si la dette de notre pays a été
multiplié par deux au cours des
dernières années
il n'est pas de la responsabilité de
l'europe si les dépenses publiques n'ont
pas été maîtrisé au point d'avoir vu les
déficits de notre pays se creuser
sensiblement et notamment le déficit
structurel qui a augmenté de deux points
entre 2007 et 2012
il ne pas de la responsabilité de
l'europe de d'avoir vu le déficit du
commerce extérieur et par conséquent la
perte de compétitivité de nos industries
consacré et si nous voulons rétablir nos
comptes c'est parce que nous ne voulons
pas que les marchés portent atteinte à
notre souveraineté
parce que si nous perdions de vue la
nécessité du rétablissement de nos
comptes publics alors nous subirions sur
les marchés financiers à l'instar
d'autres pays d'europe du sud
des attaques spéculatives qui pourrait
avoir des effets récessifs considérable
et altérer l'efficacité de notre
économie je veux simplement rappeler que
1 point de taux d'intérêt supplémentaire
sur les marchés c'est la première année
2 milliards qu'il faut absorber la
seconde plus de 4 milliards et en dix
ans près de 10 milliards c'est donc une
vraie difficulté pour nous que cette
situation il nous faut y faire face en
étant en maîtrise le deuxième point sur
lequel je voudrais insister c'est que ce
que nous faisons en matière de
rétablissement des comptes n'est pas
antinomique de ce que nous voulons pour
la croissance et pour l'investissement
les 20 milliards d'euros d'investis dans
les projets numériques pour notre
territoire en disant ce que nous voulons
faire en termes d'investissements pour
le grand paris ce que nous voulons faire
en matière de logement sous l'impulsion
de cécile duflot à travers l'abaissement
de la tva pour la construction de
logements neufs
tout ça ce sont des investissements
massifs pour demain qui doivent
permettre de faire de la croissance et
de l'emploi enfin je conclurai en vous
disant qu'il y a dans la politique de ce
gouvernement une ambition de justice
sociale qui s'est traduite au cours des
derniers mois par de nouvelles
dispositions concernant les droits de
succession la remise en oeuvre de la
progressivité de l'impôt sur la fortune
la création d'une nouvelle tranche à 45%
l'alignement de la fiscalité du travail
sur celle du capital autant d'éléments
qui témoigne de l'ambition de justice
sociale qui est la nôtre
merci merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à françoise laborde du
groupe rds vous avez la parole chez
colette
merci madame la présidente la semaine
dernière monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez annoncé que les 35 mesures du
pacte national pour la croissance la
compétitivité l'emploi issu de
l'excellent rapport de louis gallois
sont toutes engagées et que deux tiers
d'entre elles sont d'ores et déjà mises
en oeuvre certaines réformes très
importantes nécessitant l'aval du
parlement ont déjà été adoptées et
d'ailleurs notre groupe les a toutes
soutenues
je pense à la création de la bpi ou au
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi ou
plus récemment à l'accord sur l'emploi
qui de l'aveu même de louis gallois est
étroitement lié au pacte de
compétitivité
aujourd'hui l'essentiel est de maintenir
le cap en effet une mise en oeuvre
partielle de ces mesures serait inutile
voire contre-productive
le pacte est un coup tout cohérent aussi
pour redresser notre économie est il
indispensable de poursuivre la mise en
oeuvre de l'ensemble des 35 mesure cela
doit constituer la seule véritable
priorité de la majorité présidentielle
car il s'agit avant tout de retrouver la
croissance et des marges de manoeuvre
l'essentiel est bien là
votre mobilisation notre mobilisation en
faveur de la croissance doit être totale
et toutes les composantes de la majorité
mais aussi de l'opposition doivent en
avoir conscience
c'est une question d'intérêt national
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
déclaré le redressement de la france ne
se fera pas en un jour
l'allemagne elle a mis dix ans pour se
redresser il faudra sûrement du temps
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ne faut
pas dévier de cette trajectoire
exigeante mais indispensable et j'ajoute
que la politique volontariste de la
france en matière de compétitivité et
d'emploi n'a de sens aujourd'hui que si
elle mise en cohérence au niveau
européen une véritable coordination des
politiques économiques et une politique
active de l'abaisser
permettant une baisse de l'euro sont
désormais indispensable pour restaurer
la confiance et la croissance
persévérance ténacité et cohérent ce
sont les clés de l'efficacité et de la
réussite des réformes engagées dans ces
conditions monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous informer le sénat en
dressant un état des lieux de la mise en
oeuvre à ce jour des 35 mesures du pacte
mais également sur la suite du
calendrier parlementaire est réaffirmé
devant la représentation nationale
la détermination du gouvernement à
poursuivre sur ce chemin exigeant je
vous remercie
merci madame laborde la parole est
toujours un monsieur bernard cazeneuve
ministre chargé du budget merci beaucoup
madame la sénatrice pour votre question
qui rend bien compte de l'ensemble des
sujets dont nous avons à traiter si nous
voulons rétablir durablement la
compétitivité de l'économie française et
organiser le retour de la croissance
d'abord vous avez raison de souligner
qu'une grande partie des questions qui
touchent à la compétitivité renvoi des
initiatives qui doivent être poursuivis
approfondie au sein de l'union
européenne il faut d'abord que les
institutions financières notamment
bancaire soit assaini pour être en
situation de nouveau de financer les
entreprises ce qui signifie que nous
devons accélérer le calendrier de mise
en oeuvre de l'union bancaire nous
sommes tombés d'accord sur un mécanisme
de supervision des banques qu'ils
appellent un mécanisme de résolution des
crises bancaires et de garantie des
dépôts
vous avez vu que dans l'élan donné par
la mise en oeuvre de l'union bancaire la
banque de france la banque centrale
européenne pardonnez-moi par
l'intermédiaire de son programme out
wright monetary transaction a mis en
place un dispositif d'intervention sur
le marché secondaire des dettes
souveraines qui a permis de diminuer les
taux d'intérêt il nous faut par
conséquent amplifier la remise en ordre
de la finance et la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale au sein de l'union
européenne doit permettre de faire en
sorte que l'achèvement de la remise en
ordre de la finance au plan européen
international soit possible c'est une
première condition de la compétitivité
faire en sorte que la finance soit
capable à nouveau de finances et
d'économie
deuxièmement il faut aller au bout des
dispositifs que nous avons mis en place
vous avez rappelé la déclaration de
monsieur le premier ministre sur le
pacte de compétitivité avec ses 35
mesures nous accélérons la mise en
oeuvre de ces 35 mesures et notamment la
mise en oeuvre sur les territoires du
cic eux c'est aujourd'hui une enveloppe
de 400 millions qui est mobilisé et la
banque publique d'investissement a été
activé de manière à pouvoir assurer la
vence du crédit d'impôt dès 2013 et les
entreprises qui le souhaitent pourront
sous 15 jours
bénéficiez d'à peu près 85 % du crédit
d'impôt dont elles peuvent bénéficier
dès 2013 ce qui est très important pour
les entreprises qui sont confrontées à
des difficultés de trésorerie et les
banques privées pourront elles aussi
grâce à la garantie de la bpi à hauteur
de 50 % des sommes qu'elles avanceront
pouvoir utilement intervenir pour
favoriser la mise en oeuvre de ce crédit
d'impôt enfin insiste sur le fait que
sous l'impulsion de fleur pellerin
d'arnaud montebourg
les filières les entreprises innovantes
sont grandement aidé par les dispositifs
gouvernementaux et lance les assises de
l'entrepreneuriat qui se tiendront lundi
sont l'occasion de témoigner de
l'ensemble des mesures que nous prenons
en faveur des entreprises pour les
dynamiser
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
par antoine lefèvre pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
madame la présidente monsieur premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice madame la
garde des sceaux
je veux revenir sur ce qu'a publié hier
leur site atlantico le désormais célèbre
mur des cons intro bino scop de
responsables politiques de droite
principalement de syndicalistes
policiers de haut magistrat le
journaliste voir ce collage murale d'un
homme politique de droite comme de
gauche y compris votre collègue de
l'intérieur monsieur valls en dit long
d'ailleurs sur les rapports police
magistrats
mais que fait plus consternant figurent
des parents de victimes de récidivistes
l'une violer et tuer par guy georges
l'autre tuée de 34 coups de couteau dans
un rer ses parents meurtris dans leur
chaire en commis la faute alors suprême
milité contre la récidive
ce qui leur vaut aux yeux de certain de
figurer sur ce mur de la honte
vous avez répondu hier à mon collègue
luc chatel qu'aucune entrave ne sera
faite aux procédures que les personnes
visées engagerait c'est encore heureux
la présidente du syndicat auteurs de ce
mur scandaleux parle de défouloir de
blague de potache mais dans cette
affaire nous ne sommes pas en présence
de lycéens ou d'étudiants à l'humour
potache ni même à l'école de la
magistrature
nous sommes dans les locaux d'un
syndicat professionnel des juges dont on
attend une impartialité exemplaires une
catégorie professionnelle comme celle de
la magistrature censée être la plus
neutre de la république ne peut se
permettre de s'enfermer dans une
idéologie politique car c'est ce dont
nous parlons ici
elle doit juger de façon équitable la
dérive de ce syndicat pose question
notre propos n'est pas de stigmatiser la
justice en général mais le comportement
de certains qui semble oublier l'essence
même de leur indépendance dont ils sont
si jaloux et que vous ne cessez de nous
rappeler madame la garde des sceaux
cela ne peut que susciter questionnement
sur leur impartialité nouveau t-il pas
la porte à une légitime suspicion c'est
la confiance que placent en eux la
société qui est ainsi ébranlé cela
laisse planer de dangereuses augure sur
les propositions du président de la
république désireux de donner plus
d'indépendance encore au conseil de la
magistrature
ce que vous avez qualifié d' action
malheureuse madame la garde des sceaux
est en fait une faute grave
le ministère public peut prendre
l'initiative d'une action publique
je vous cite alors madame la garde des
sceaux je vous le demande
faites le et faites le
façon très claire je vous remercie merci
chers collègues l'appareil d'état
chritiane taubira garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice madame la
présidente mesdames dessinatrice
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur lefebvre vous devriez me citer
complètement parce que vous savez que
j'ai dit à votre collègue de
l'opposition à l'assemblée nationale que
je trouve cet acte inadmissible je peux
ajouter qu'il est insupportable je veux
ajouter qu'il est stupide et malsain et
il est temps que le syndicat de la
magistrature se rendent compte que la
période stupide et malsaine est passé et
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin qu'ils n'ont pas
besoin effectivement de prendre des
risques sur l'image de neutralité de la
magistrature
j'ai comme vous sans doute le souci de
distinguer le corps de la magistrature
ces magistrats qui exercent leurs
mission de juger noble mission au
quotidien avec dignité de ceux qui se
sont livrés à cet acte qui se sont
abaissées à se livrer à cet acte ceci
étant dit vous savez bien qu'en qualité
de garde des sceaux moi même je ne peux
pas méconnaître la loi et qu'on ne peut
considérer comme une faute disciplinaire
un acte commis dans un local syndical
est révélée par des images volées
j'ai saisi le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature pour lui demander s'il peut
apprécier
sylvia manquement à la déontologie
ce syndicat a pris des risques sur
l'ensemble du corps de la magistrature
et notamment sur ses propres membres
à en juger par les menaces de récusation
sur les procédures en cours
c'est dommageable à l'ensemble du corps
j'espère que nous en sortirons parce que
ce qui est important c'est
qu'effectivement notre magistrature
retrouve sa noblesse que nous puissions
la débarrasser du soupçon qui pèse sur
son impartialité et que les relations
soient tes classiques entre le corps de
la magistrature et l'exécutif
merci
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
notre collègue hervé marseille pour le
groupe
udi bus et madame le président monsieur
le premier ministre mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
où est l'état où est le gouvernement où
est le président de la république
ces questions c'était le candidat
françois hollande en visite à petroplus
qu'il est posé il y a à peine un an déjà
une éternité
ces questions nous lui posons
aujourd'hui à notre tour le candidat
hollande se voulait volontariste
il montait sur les camions de la cgt est
déclarée au bourget le 22 janvier 2012
que l'arrêt industrie
réindustrialisation de la france sera sa
priorité
vous aussi monsieur le ministre
montebourg vous avez exprimé une volonté
vous qui affirmiez à différentes
reprises que l'étape beaucoup
aujourd'hui cette volonté se heurte à
l'écueil de la dure réalité échec sur le
dossier petroplus le tribunal de
commerce a rejeté les deux offres en
lice il n'y aura donc ni participation
de l'état ni repreneur même constat du
côté de florange où les hauts fourneaux
viennent d'être fermés et que dire de
psa qui accélère ces fermetures à
aulnay-sous-bois de goodyear à amiens
nord d'alcatel lucent des difficultés de
renault
et l'on pourrait hélas sans citer des
dizaines d'autres sanofi fralib virgin
samsonite faurecia le cimetière des
espoirs déçus vient d'être inauguré à
florange où les salariés ont installé
hier une stèle aux promesses non tenues
du président de la république stèle
promptement démonter par le maire
socialiste de la commune
face à cela que fait le gouvernement il
a pris acte
il a pris acte des fermetures des
licenciements de son impuissance et du
désarroi des ouvriers
ma question est donc très simple
monsieur le ministre puisqu'il ya un
ministère du redressement productif
quel est son rôle à quoi sert-il et
quels et la stratégie industrielle du
gouvernement
la parole la parole d'arnaud montebourg
ministre du redressement productif
monsieur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur marseille vous
évoquez un dossier parmi tant d'autres
qui avait donné lieu c'est vrai à des
déclarations dont je peux traduire de
mémoire le contenu
petroplus est réglé qui avait dit ça
nicolas sarkozy beaucoup de choses
avaient été réglés mais on s'est aperçu
que finalement il ne l'était pas alors
il est vrai que en ce qui nous concerne
nous sommes bien gardé de dire que
c'était réglé car nous connaissions la
difficulté de ce dossier
il fallait trouver un repreneur capable
de mettre un demi milliard sur la table
pour reconstruire cette raffinerie avoir
du pétrole qui soit acceptable honorable
c'est à dire qu'il ne viole pas des
embargos
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
notamment iranien et il fallait en plus
que l'entrepreneur acceptent une perte
de 50 millions chaque année en attendant
la reconstruction de l'appareil
industriel
c'est vrai nous n'avons pas réussi à
trouver ce repreneur
nous nous sommes démenés en liaison avec
des partenaires fiables que sont les
organisations syndicales
l'administrateur judiciaire les
magistrats du tribunal de commerce
les deux derniers repreneurs qui sont
restés en lice n'avait pas l'argent que
nous n'avons eu de cesse de leur
demander de mettre sur la table pour
obtenir la crédibilité d'un repreneur
qui ne reprennent pas une raffinerie
obsolète pour finalement six mois plus
tard après avoir mangé la trésorerie
restantes être incapable de financer le
plan social que nous avons su améliorer
en liaison est en négociation avec shell
je dois vous dire que lorsque shell
s'est débarrassé en 2008 de cet outil
industriel
il eût été intéressant que vous posiez
votre question il n'en a jamais été
question des raffineries à cette époque
alors vous me demandez mais à quoi sert
le redressement productif monsieur
marcel
et bien je vous réponde il sert à sauver
mille emplois chez gm strasbourg et les
alsaciens le savent il a servi à sauver
520 salariés chessy lynx dans l'eure et
les normands le savent il a servi à
sauver 220 200 salariés chez m real dans
l'eure les normands le savent il a servi
grâce à l'intervention de monsieur le
premier ministre a évité la chute des
chantiers navals de stx 4000 salariés
les nantais est ce un nazairien le
savent il a servi à sauver l'entreprise
clestra 280 13 emplois mc bras et 93
salariés dans l'auvergne mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs auvergnats vous
ne le savez pas vous étiez là lorsque je
suis venu sur place annoncé que les 350
salariés d'assez ces spécialistes de la
maintenance ferroviaire seraient assurés
de leur avenir par la commande publique
vous étiez là mais là vous ne savez plus
est ce que je peux vous parler de samro
des 210 emplois de l'or 720 emploi
dalkia 101 salariés de m hainaut en
bretagne 123 salariés et combien
d'autres redressement productif
ce ne sont pas les dossiers médiatisés
que le figaro choisi dans votre esprit
monsieur le sénateur pour stigmatiser
une action qui est difficile sous vous
conclure de son ouvrage et constance et
persévérant
la parole est à jacques bernard magner
pour les groupes socialistes et
apparentés
madame la présidente monsieur le premier
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le ministre
suite à la remise du rapport de la
mission sur l'enseignement de la morale
laïque vous souhaité introduire à la
rentrée 2015 une nouvelle discipline
dans les établissements scolaires du
cours préparatoire à la terminale afin
de faire partager les valeurs de la
république
il s'agit de la morale laïque depuis
l'instruction morale et civique mis en
place par jules ferry en même temps que
l'école primaire laïque et obligatoire
divers intitulé ont été données à cet
enseignement mais ils ont tous le même
but
l'apprentissage des règles collectives
pour agir et bien vivre ensemble
selon un idéal commun de liberté
d'égalité et de fraternité
la construction du libre arbitre de
chacun le respect de toutes les
convictions et de toutes les croyances
bref la construction du futur citoyen
l'instauration de cours de morale laïque
répondent à une demande forte de la
communauté éducative et des parents
d'élèves en particulier notre société
est fortement attachée à la liberté
individuelle de penser et ressentent un
malaise fort face au repli identitaire
et communautaire qui se développe sur
fond de crise économique et sociale
dans ce contexte monsieur le ministre
saluons votre initiative qui relie ainsi
l'individu au collectif avec la loi pour
la refondation de l'école avec la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire avec l'
embauche de 60000 enseignants
supplémentaires en cinq ans la mise en
oeuvre de cette nouvelle discipline
viendra compléter la palette des moyens
dégagés par le gouvernement pour enrayer
le déclin éducatif de notre pays
relevés par les enquêtes internationales
pendant les dix dernières années la
morale laïque
cette nouvelle matière sera définie par
le futur conseil national des programmes
organisme indépendant
et pour lui donner toute l'importance
qu'elle mérite
vous souhaitez monsieur le ministre que
son enseignement fasse l'objet d'une
évaluation
monsieur le ministre en quoi la morale
laïque se différenciera tel de
l'instruction civique déjà dispensés par
nos enseignants comment les professeurs
qui devront assurer cette formation
sauront-ils à leur tour former et enfin
quelle forme prendra l'évaluation de ce
nouvel enseignement puisque vous le
jugez à juste titre indispensable
j'en ai assez la parole la parole est à
vincent peillon ministre de l'éducation
nationale madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur manier l'école
d'aujourd'hui c'est la france de demain
et c'est une responsabilité particulière
pour tous évidemment c'est une des
responsabilités du gouvernement
j'écoutais tout leur mon collègue
bernard cazeneuve de préparer l'avenir
après tant d'années où il a été sacrifié
par l'accroissement de la dette mais
aussi par l'abandon précisément de
l'école de la république
l'école a toujours eu trois missions une
première mission qui est d'instruire
en dix ans la france a plongé dans
toutes les évaluations internationales
et 25 % de nos élèves sont aujourd'hui
en difficulté
les professeurs ne sont même plus
remplacés ils ne sont pas formés et
c'est le résultat de dix ans d'action de
votre majorité
c'est pour cela que nous avons décidé
non seulement de créer des postes 60000
en cinq ans mais de former les
enseignants de revoir les programmes
elle a aussi une mission importante
l'insertion professionnelle des jeunes
lorsque la gauche est parti en 2002 10 %
des jeunes étaient au chômage 25 %
aujourd'hui le même chiffre qu'on avait
trouvé en 1997
c'est pour cela que nous allons revoir
le système d'orientation les cartes de
formation professionnelle le parcours
d'orientation et d'information et de
rapprochement avec les entreprises avec
le premier ministre au mois de juin
nous installerons le conseil éducation
entreprises et puis
l'école a pour mission de transmettre
des valeurs ces valeurs qui nous
permette de vivre ensemble dans la
tradition républicaine politique et
morale sont inséparables il ne faut pas
obéir à la loi uniquement par crainte du
chant team du châtiment et par la
contrainte mais par une obligation
intérieur ç'a toujours été notre
tradition commune elle a été perdu et
oublier la laïcité incarne précisément
et la morale laïque cela j'ai bien noté
des craintes première crainte cette
morale laïque serait contre les
orientations religieuses et les choix de
certains celle inverse
le président de cette assemblée il ya
longtemps le grand républicain jules
ferry keane quitté jamais le petit
ouvrage l'enseignement du peuple de
guinée avait bien dit que la laïcité
était ce la seule qui permettrait à
toutes les convictions de vivre
pacifiquement dans l'espace commun de la
république notre laïcité n'est pas anti
religieuse elle est la garante lui de la
liberté de chacun c'est celle-ci qui est
en question aujourd'hui
et puis une deuxième crainte celle d'une
morale d'état non notre tradition c'est
celle de l'individualisme républicain il
n'y a pas de morale d'état c'est
précisément quand on a fait la morale
laïque qu'on a été capables ensemble
république sociale et république l'autre
libéral de se lever dans l' affaire
dreyfus moment où la liberté la justice
se sont conjugués voilà ce que nous
devons donner aux enfants de la
république notre redressement économique
nous le conduiront il doit s'accompagner
d'un redressement intellectuelle et
morale la parole que tu as corinne
bouchoux pour le groupe écologiste
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues qui ont bien voulu rester pour
ces questions d'actualité ma question
s'adresse à tous et à tout puisqu'elle
concerne les modalités notre fin de vie
nous y serons tous confrontés un jour
indépendamment du choix de certains de
terminer leurs jours à domicile ceux qui
ont les moyens peuvent se permettre des
résidences plus ou moins confortable et
pour beaucoup le lot des ehpad
nous savons tous de qualité
kalou le personnel fait de son mieux
pour que la fin de vie se passe dans la
dignité
madame la ministre comment envisagez
vous les choix possibles de chacun en
matière de mode de vie lorsque on ne
peut plus rester seul chez soi que
pensez vous des projets duty baba yaga à
montreuil qui permettent un projet
construit en amont et de choisir une vie
une fan vie basé sur la cohabitation
entre générations et un projet de
dignité
ma question aura aussi un autre volet
qui malheureusement aussi concerne tout
le monde concerne nos proches et nous
concernera un jour pouvez vous nous
donner des nouvelles de la proposition
21 de la dernière campagne où il était
question de pouvoir choisir la fin de
vie digne pour chacun
chacun sait que la loi leonetti qui pour
certains a représenté un progrès est une
loi insuffisante le rapport si carla
montrer donc quid de la possibilité d'un
débat serein plus tard sur la fin de vie
assister
quid de la de la demande de certains du
droit au suicide assisté donc pouvez
vous nous éclairer sur le calendrier que
vous envisagez sur cette question qui
concerne tout le monde
au plus profond de lui-même je vous
remercie la réponse
la parole est à michel veyronnet
ministre chargée des personnes âgées de
l'autonomie monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice vous tous je vous
madame la présidente pardonnez moi
particulièrement madame la présidente
permettez moi tout d'abord d'excusés
madame touraine qui est actuellement
justement retenu à l'assemblée nationale
sur le projet de loi leonetti visant à
renforcer les droits des personnes en
fin de vie elle m'a confié sa réponse
s'agissant de ce sujet ô combien
difficile
vous le savez le président de la
république a confié une mission
professeur cigares et son rapport il lui
a été remis à redescendre
la mission s'est appuyé sur 10 débat
citoyen des auditions des enquêtes en
vas afin de recueillir
la diversité des points de vue elle a
établi une série de constats de
propositions suite à la remise du
professeur sica le président a pris acte
du constat posé pour l'organisation de
la prise en charge de la fin de vie dans
notre pays
insuffisante formation des médecins
développement insuffisant de la prise en
charge palliative des balades problème
de leur prise en charge admissible
le président a ainsi annoncé que la
ministre de la désert social et de la
santé est ainsi que la ministre de la
recherche et de l'enseignement supérieur
annoncerait des mesures visant à
améliorer cette prise en charge
le président a également pris acte du
costa établi que malgré les apports
indéniable de la loi léonetti la légion
la législation en cours ne permet pas
d'europe répondre à l'ensemble des
préoccupations
il a donc été décidé de saisir le comité
consultatif national d'éthique f afin
que celui ci puisse se prononcer sur les
trois pistes d'évolution de la
législation qui ont été ouvertes
comment et dans quelles conditions
recueillir et appliquer les directives
anticipées mise par une personne en
pleine santé avant la non à l'annonce du
maladie gras ou à l'annonce d'une
maladie grave
selon quelles modalités et conditions
strictes permettre un malade conscient
et autonome atteint d'une maladie grave
d'être accompagné et assisté dans sa
volonté de mettre un terme à sa fin de
vie
comment rendre plus digne les derniers
moments d'un patient dont les
traitements ont été interrompues à la
suite d'une décision prise à la demande
de la personne ou de sa famille merci
madame le ministre
la parole est à rémy pointereau pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
madame heures la présidente mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
par calcul politique et pour calmer une
majorité incertaine notamment sénat vous
étiez prêts à amnistier les violences
commises lors de conflits sociaux en
donnant pratiquement a permis de casser
dans cet hémicycle
il y a quelques semaines madame taubira
garde des sceaux n'avait pas hésité à
dire à l'occasion de l'examen de cette
proposition de loi d'aministie nous
sommes inspirés par le souci d'accomplir
un acte politique républicain de
concorde sociale
le sénat l'avait adopté avec des voix
socialistes
dans le même temps vous casser le droit
de manifester qui est un des droits
fondamentaux dans toute démocratie quand
vous réprimées avec violence des
manifestations pacifiques comme celles
qui ont permis à plusieurs millions de
français d'exprimer leur opposition au
mariage pour tous et à ses conséquences
rappelez vous les propos du candidat
hollande qui promettait d'être à
l'écouté des français
il disait moi président j'engagerai de
grand débat citoyen il y aurait ainsi
deux poids deux mesures dans les coudes
de la contestation
amnistie pour les casseurs répression
pour les manifestants pacifiques
et puis hier matin on apprenait que
finalement le gouvernement ne soutenait
plus la proposition de loi d'aministie
communiste adopté par le sénat
nous nous en réjouissons mais ainsi vous
désavouer donc votre propre majorité au
sénat hier matin aussi le projet de loi
dit de moralisation politique était
présenté en conseil des ministres quel
bel écran de fumée entre une réalité que
vous ne voulez pas voir ce qu'ils ont
failli chez vous et l'opinion coin 10.6
dans ce malheureux encore entre votre
projet d' amnistie sociale pour des
casseurs
le projet de loi de moralisation
politique je vous rappelle
l' affaire dsk entre autres puis le
mensonge éhonté de monsieur cahuzac et
en même temps vous aurait annoncé aux
élèves qu'ils auront à nouveau des cours
de morale qu'est l'exemplarité vous
donner avec toujours ce même principe
faites ce que je dis ne faites pas ce
que je fais toutes ses contradictions
ses manipulations d'opinion ces
mensonges de peuvent asseoir un pouvoir
vous le discréditer en contraire et pour
cacher vos erreurs vous voulez dans le
même temps aussi discréditer toute la
classe politique
10 qui centre dans sa grande majorité
fait son travail avec conscience
les français ne sont pas dupes ils
veulent que vous vous attaquer aux vrais
problèmes économiques et sociaux le
chômage le pouvoir d'achat
l'insécurité vous êtes en place depuis
près d'un an vous faut qu'on gagne à
redonner de la consistance au mot
gouverner quand allez-vous prendre vos
responsabilités et arrêter de rejeter la
faute sur les autres
la parole étant un média main najat
vallaud-belkacem milices des droits des
femmes porte parole du gouvernement
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur point trop pour répondre à
votre question le gouvernement n'a
jamais été favorable à la proposition de
loi que vous évoquez portant sur la
mystique sociale le gouvernement n'y a
jamais été favorable pour une raison
précise que je vais rappeler à nouveau
par construction nous estimons que
l'amnistié remettent en cause les
décisions de justice et donc nous ne
sommes pas favorables à une telle remise
en cause nous considérons au contraire
et vous feriez bien d'en prendre un peu
de grain aussi que seul le respect de la
loi le respect de la décision
démocratiquement adopté doit s'imposer
quel que soit le sujet quel que soit le
sujet est évoqué et que ce respect de la
loi républicaine est sans doute la
meilleure façon de sortir notre pays de
l'ornière dans laquelle vous l'avez mis
à bien des égards pour poursuivre sur
les questions
que vous adresser au gouvernement
portant sur la cohérence de son action
monsieur le sénateur le temps du bilan
n'est pas venu et pourtant et pourtant
je me prêterai de bonne grâce à cet
exercice
tant il est vrai que je suis fier
d'appartenir à un gouvernement qui a
d'ores et déjà à peine onze mois après
sa prise de responsabilité respecter la
quasi totalité des 60 engagements du
président de la république françois
hollande
plus encore que respecter ses
engagements
ce gouvernement fait front car en ce
moment gouverner c'est faire front et
donc monsieur le sénateur je vais vous
le redire la cohérence de notre action
c'est celle qui consiste à redresser le
pays redresser le pays dans la justice
dans l'égalité lui donner des
perspectives ce souffle qui lui a
cruellement manqué ces dernières années
lui permettre de se projeter dans un
avenir dans lequel nous voulons lui
redonner confiance
alors pour ce faire monsieur le sénateur
sachez que il faut du courage c'est ce
dont vous avez beaucoup manqué ces
dernières années oui il se trouve que
notre gouvernement a eu le courage du
sérieux budgétaire
le sel qui nous permette d'avoir comme
premier budget de l'état n'ont pas le
remboursement des intérêts de la dette
mais l'éducation mais la justice mais la
santé nous en sommes fiers
oui nous avons eu le courage de nous
attaquer totalement ce que vous n'aviez
pas fait à la bataille de l'emploi en
faisant confiance au dialogue social en
faisant confiance le dialogue social que
vous aviez piétiner mais aussi en allant
plus loin en adoptant un pacte de
compétitivité beaucoup plus ambitieux
que vous n'auriez même osé le rêver en
adoptant une sécurisation des parcours
professionnels qui était devenu un
serpent de mer ces dernières années en
apportant des réponses à une jeunesse
qui sous votre gouvernance se désespérer
dans ce pays
nous en sommes fiers enfin le
gouvernement auquel j'appartiens
messieurs mesdames les sénateurs a le
courage aussi de faire avancer la
société en adoptant des réformes
d'égalité qui font grandir sa devise
liberté égalité fraternité
voilà cette question pour conclure mon
propos monsieur le sénateur et vous quel
est votre cohérence est ce que vous
le courage d'adopter les textes qui vont
intensifier la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale
les textes qui vont imposer de la
probité de la transparence de la vie
publique
les textes qui vont garantir
l'indépendance du conseil supérieur de
la magistrature
les électeurs vous attendent la parole
la parole et à yves daudigny
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
déléguée chargée des personnes âgées et
de l'autonomie votre ministère madame la
ministre et celui des bonnes nouvelles
la première bonne nouvelle a été très
concrètement hier l'annoncent en marge
de la réunion du conseil de la caisse
nationale de solidarité pour l'autonomie
de l'apport de 100 millions de crédits
nouveaux pour la médicalisation des
établissements pour personnes âgées dont
case viendront abonder les 147 voter et
85 en anticipation d'engagement et de
120 millions pour les plans des aides à
l'investissement 2013 soit au total 220
millions supplémentaires qui
contribueront également à réduire le
reste à charge des personnes âgées en
établissement
la seconde bonne nouvelle et le résultat
effectif de votre action pour réduire la
sous consommation des crédits
la troisième bonne nouvelle est que les
deux précédentes traduisent le
changement radical de perspective et
d'appréhension du vieillissement à pulsé
par votre ministère
le changement est en effet frappant
entre il y à peu le catastrophisme d'un
précédent gouvernement annonçant des
coûts insupportables à charge de la
collectivité
on évoquait jusqu'à 34 milliards qui n'a
rien prévu pour autant et l'autre regard
la vision d'avenir que vous portez
aujourd'hui madame la ministre vous avez
su voir dans l'avancée en âge
la prévention et l'accompagnement de la
perte d'autonomie les potentialités de
croissance qu'il recèle le moteur
économique il constitue par la création
d'emplois non délocalisables
des services à la personne le
développement des technologies du
numérique leurs répercussions bénéfiques
pour tous les secteurs d'activité et il
est vrai que le secteur de la prise en
charge de la perte d'autonomie ne
connaît pas la crise comment un test
l'essor des principaux groupes
gestionnaire de maisons de retraite qui
connaissent une progression de leur
bénéfice de 7 à 20 %
merci madame ministre de nous préciser
votre projet et ce formidable challenge
que représente la silver economy lui ai
écouté ça vous intéressera et pour
l'avenir économique de la france et pour
le bien-être de la population
merci chers collègues la parole est à
michèle delaunay ministre des personnes
âgées et de l'autonomie vous avez raison
monsieur solis monsieur le sénateur
dolynny mon ministère est porteur
d'avenir d'innovation et de bonnes
nouvelles et par exemple les ans 62
millions que j'ai dégagé pour cette
seule année pour la médicalisation
permettra bien sûr en premier lieu de
mettre plus de personnel autour des
âgées en maison de retraite mais aussi
la création de plusieurs milliers
d'emplois vous en région réjouir et cher
ami deuxièmement cette bonne nouvelle
n'est évidemment pas la seule
et le principal est peut-être de faire
que ce qui a été le plus grand progrès
du 20e siècle
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie soit
aujourd'hui pour notre pays une
opportunité et une chance dans nos
entreprises doivent se saisir et nous
avons tous les atouts pour cela par
exemple et en premier des territoires
déjà très engagée sur le sujet et qu'ils
sauront se saisir des nouvelles
technologies un gouvernement pour lequel
la question de l'âge constitue une
priorité qui prépare vous savez un
projet de loi comportant un volet
anticipation ou céser où ces entreprises
seront bien dans ces entreprises seront
bien sûr les partenaires mais aussi un
tissu industriel déjà très performant
sur le sujet avec plusieurs leaders
mondiaux en particulier dans le champ de
la domotique et une foison de start-up
que je vais rencontrer dans tous mes
déplacements et qui sont vraiment
monitrice d'innovation et de changement
radical de la vision que nous pouvons
avoir du vieillissement
pourtant tout cela n'est pas assez et
nous il faut à ce secteur une
organisation ils font définir des
priorités
il faut mettre tous les acteurs ensemble
ils font trouver des financements
d'amorçage et tout cela c'est ce qu'avec
le ministre arnaud montebourg
nous avons entrepris hier à bercy devant
700 partenaires de cette silver economy
économies liées à l'âge qui les plus
grandes entreprises
les experts les décideurs les
représentants des territoires et la
recherche universitaire et tout cela est
aujourd'hui en marche et avec le
concours de tous
je crois pouvoir dire que nous avons
aujourd'hui les moyens de faire de la
silver et d'économie un atout pour notre
pays et je vous rappelle que ce secteur
connaît aujourd'hui 15% de croissance
aux états unis
oui monsieur le ministre la révolution
de l'âge est en marche et nous la
porterons tous ensemble
messi
la parole est à alain fauconnier pour le
groupe socialiste et apparentés madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues il y a deux ans la
majorité de gauche du sénat intronisé
par voie d'amendement l'action de groupe
dans le cadre du projet de loi du
précédent gouvernement renforçant les
droits la protection et l'information
des consommateurs
cet amendement s'inspirait du rapport
des sénateurs bétail ou qui révélait une
grande lacune du droit français
l'absence de moyens de recours collectif
au service de camp des consommateurs
lésés cette lacune autorise la
persistance d'un déséquilibre entre le
simple consommateur victime et
l'entreprise coupable
pourtant à travers l'europe et au delà
de ses frontières
les législateurs ont répondu à cette
nécessité de permettre aux consommateurs
ayant subi même préjudice d'obtenir par
une mutualisation des moyens
un déménagement juste bien sûr les
dérives sont observés notamment aux
états unis
l'application du principe du triple de
dédommagement peut aisément entraîné la
faillite de l'entreprise responsable
le précédent gouvernement s'est opposé
avec la plus grande véhémence à cette
disposition si nécessaire à la
protection des consommateurs
il satisfaisait ainsi par cette position
ceux qui ont intérêt à ce que le
consommateur est sans défense face à des
previews de plus en plus nombreux
françois hollande alors candidat à
l'élection présidentielle exprimé sa
volonté de mettre la justice au service
du droit de la république et des
français en instaurant une action de
groupe pour que les citoyens victimes
des mêmes préjudices puissent obtenir
réparation
le 14 novembre dernier le gouvernement a
acté en conseil des ministres
l'introduction d'une action de groupe à
la française
je sais monsieur le ministre est
qu'après avoir saisi le conseil national
la consommation avoir lancé une large
consultation publique et avoir consulté
les nombreux rapports et avis publié sur
le sujet vous vous apprêtez à présenter
au parlement un projet de loi instaurant
l'action de groupe dans notre droit
ainsi ma question porte sur la forme que
vous envisagez
cette action de groupe à la française
comment pensez vous ouvrir la
possibilité aux consommateurs ayant subi
des dommages individuels de se
coordonner pour obtenir une juste
réparation
comment dans le contexte difficile que
nous connaissons répondre aux
inquiétudes des entreprises concernant
les excès des recours collectifs observé
par ailleurs je vous remercie
la parole est à benoît hamon ministre
chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la consommation merci
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je vais prendre
deux exemples assez parlant le 19
septembre 2000 le conseil de la
concurrence qui est devenu aujourd'hui
l'autorité de la concurrence sanctionné
plusieurs banques pour une entente
anticoncurrentielle dans le secteur du
crédit immobilier pour 160 millions
d'euros un milliard de francs à l'époque
le 1er décembre 2005 le conseil
constitutionnel sélectionné cette fois
ci trois opérateurs de la téléphonie
mobile
là encore pour une entente
anticoncurrentielle hauteur de 534
millions d'euros
ces deux pénalités ont été directement
dans les caisses de l'état
les seules personnes qui n'ont jamais
été indemnisé du préjudice qu'ils ont
subi
ce sont les consommateurs raison pour
laquelle devant cette lacune du droit
français depuis de nombreuses années
beaucoup de responsables politiques
on souhaitait créer l'action de groupe à
la française je vais y revenir
ça a été le cas de jacques chirac
candidat à l'élection présidentielle qui
a souhaité le mettre là mettre en oeuvre
pour des raisons qui ne m'appartient pas
de commenter ça n'a pas été possible
ça a été le cas de nicolas sarkozy qui a
souhaité la mettre en oeuvre pour des
raisons qu'il ne m'appartient pas de
commenter mais qui sont sans doute les
mêmes que pour jacques chirac a choisi
de ne pas les mettre en oeuvre nous
avons voulu nous le 2 mai c'est à dire
la semaine prochaine inscrire dans le
projet de loi de consommation la
création des actions de groupe
l'action de groupe permettra quoi elle
permettra aux consommateurs de pouvoir
obtenir réparation du préjudice qu'ils
ont subi
dans le champ des contrats de
consommation et des pratiques
anticoncurrentielles nous voulons que
deux fêtes demain quand un certain
nombre de grands groupes constituent des
rentes économique au détriment du
consommateur
et bien ce consommateur puisse être
indemnisé or aujourd'hui c'est le pot de
terre contre le pot de fer
et il est extrêmement compliqué pour un
consommateur d'obtenir réparation du
préjudice qu'il a subi
parce que seul il ne parvient pas à
aller au bout de la procédure qu'il veut
intenter c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous allons organiser ces actions groupe
de telle manière à ce qu'elles
permettent aux consommateurs à travers
des associations de consommateurs
agréées de pouvoir porter des procédures
ce sera une arme de dissuasion massive
nous espérons qu'il y aura le moins de
procédures possibles et que dé facto les
grands groupes changeront leurs
politiques pour éviter ces actions de
groupe mais nous voulons permettre aux
consommateurs à travers les associations
de consommateurs à travers des tribunaux
d'instance spécialisés de pouvoir
obtenir réparation du préjudice subi
c'est ainsi que l'action de groupe à la
française et vitrac en clair la rente
économique amassés par un certain nombre
de grands groupes a et rémunérés des
cabinets d'avocats com aux etats-unis
nous ferons en sorte que cette rente
économiques passent des entreprises vers
les consommateurs sous forme de pouvoir
d'achat c'est le sens de la mesure que
nous allons proposer dans le projet de
loi consommation et j'espère puisque
tous les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle au président de la
république sur les vingt dernières
années ont porté cette ambition là que
sur tous les bancs de cette assemblée à
l'assemblée nationale comme au sénat
au sénat nous aurons le soutien de tous
les partis politiques en faveur de cette
mesure de protection des consommateurs
je vous remercie vous ce ministre
la parole est un autre collègue robert
del picchia pour les groupes union pour
un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole chers collègues bien
madame la présidente premier n'est ce
pas là messieurs mesdames et messieurs
les
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresser au ministre des affaires
étrangères elle s'adresse toujours
d'ailleurs
mais je comprends qu'il puisse y
répondre car si je suis bien informé
il accompagne le président de la
république en chine bien alors
l'explosion de cette voiture piégée à
tripoli dont on parle depuis trois jours
soulève un certain nombre de questions
ici à paris mais aussi mes chers
collègues de graves inquiétudes pour nos
compatriotes du réseau diplomatique et
au delà de nos communautés françaises à
l'étranger
alors certes le ministre laurent fabius
a annoncé à tripoli l'envoi d'une équipe
du gign
entre temps les sur place d'ailleurs il
a également annoncé le renforcement de
la sécurité des intérêts au moyen-orient
et dans le sahel
ces annonces sont bien sûr les bienvenus
mais sont-elles suffisantes
soyons clair mes chers collègues nous le
savons tous il y à des menaces
d'al-qaïda contre la france al qaïda au
maghreb islamique aqmi a directement
menacé vendredi dernier la france de
représailles pour son intervention au
mali alors la question paraît légitime
mes chers collègues cet attentat n'était
il pas la mise à exécution de cette
menace
et surtout est-ce que l'on avait bien
pris toutes les mesures de précaution en
septembre dernier
en septembre dernier l'ambassadeur
américain christopher stevens et trois
autres ressortissants américains ont été
tués à benghazi
à la suite de cet attentat
le gouvernement libyen avait promis de
mettre sur pied une force spéciale de
protection des diplomates
or apparemment on ne voit me dit on que
de rares voitures de police libyenne qui
patrouillent de temps en temps alors
nous savons mes chers collègues que le
pouvoir libyen et pour toujours on le
sait les plus grandes difficultés à
imposer son autorité sur un pays où
d'importantes quantités d'armes sont
toujours en circulation et où de
nombreuses milices agissent à leur guise
alors étant intervenu auprès des
autorités libyennes pour plus de
sécurité pour nos compatriotes à
l'avenir
de plus en plus inquiet on peut les
comprendre mais au delà de la sécurité
de nos compatriotes les implications
politiques en libye et sur toute la
région
cet attentat est aussi un signal très
inquiétant car c'est un élément
dissuasif supplémentaires pour les
entreprises déjà réticente à les
travailler en libye et dans d'autres
pays autour le vice-premier ministre
libyen avoir un bar asie a déclaré je le
cite
nous sommes dans une période cruciale et
certains veulent déstabiliser la libye
et cette fois les auteurs de l'attentât
ont touché deux cibles à la fois la
libye et la france alors on voit mal
aujourd'hui dans ce contexte de violence
et de risques extrêmes le développement
des relations franco libyennes
alors comment peut-on les envisager nous
sommes toutefois tous ici d'accord ici à
paris mais aussi permis nos communautés
sur le terrain à l'étranger pour
réaffirmer avec force qu'il ne faut
jamais jamais cédé aux terroristes
et permettez moi au nom des français de
l'étranger madame la ministre de rendre
hommage ici
deux jeunes blessés à tripoli et au delà
à tous les membres de nos services de
sécurité qui font quotidiennement acte
de courage au service de nos
compatriotes à travers le monde merci de
votre attention
la parole est à madame hélène conway
mouret ministre chargé des français de
l'étranger
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur del picchia vous remercie pour
votre question qui me permet d'abord de
confirmer que la sécurité de nos
ressortissants français à l'étranger etc
une priorité vraiment un axe prioritaire
pour le ministère des affaires
étrangères et que c'est une question que
nous traitons avec sérénité et
responsabilité
laurent fabius en effet est parti
immédiatement à tripoli après l'annnonce
de l'attentât pour apporter son soutien
et celui du gouvernement aux deux
gendarmes blessés dont un grièvement et
qui ont été depuis rapatrié en france
le ministre s'est rendu sur place pour
exprimer notre solidarité à nos agents
consulaires qui font un travail
remarquable ainsi qu'à notre communauté
française petit certes près de 300
personnes pour prendre les mesures
nécessaires afin de renforcer leur
sécurité
ces français participent à la
reconstruction de la libye
hilti promeuvent nos intérêts mais aussi
nos valeurs et nous devons les protéger
les mesures de sécurité étaient déjà
très importante et je peux en témoigner
les décisions immédiates ont été prises
pour les renforcer encore les
différentes implantations françaises
elles l'école l'institut le service et
la mission économique ont été fermés un
groupe de gic du gign et vous y avez
fait référence est déployé à la
résidence de l'ambassade où se trouve
rapatrier la chancellerie yeux il a été
demandé à nos ressortissants français
aussi de ne pas sortir
en attendant de nouvelles instructions
vous savez que quotidiennement ils
reçoivent des consignes de la part du
post
si la france a été ciblé par cet acte
terroriste se sont bien aussi les
libyens qui en sont victimes
plus que jamais la france est déterminée
avec mon micro est déterminé à
accompagner la libye sur le chemin de
l'instabilité
le 12 février dernier laurent fabius a
présidé une conférence au quai d'orsay
afin de mobiliser la communauté
internationale
nous avons notamment prévu de former
près de 3000 policiers libyens émissions
européennes devraient arriver sur place
en juin ces actes isolés barbares sur le
fait d'extrémistes qui bafoue les idéaux
des révolutions arabes avec les libyens
et tous les peuples qui luttent pour la
liberté nous y resterons fidèles cet
acte n'a pas été revendiqué plusieurs
hypothèses sont possibles celle de la
déstabilisation interne en libye comme
celle de représailles suite à l'action
de la france contre le terrorisme
notamment en libye mais sachez que nous
ne céderons jamais à la violence les
auteurs de ces actes seront retrouvés où
qu'ils se cachent ils seront jugés
ils seront punis l' enquête a commencé à
paris et à tripoli avec la nomination
d'un juge antiterroriste
les autorités libyennes nous apportent
tous les sons tout leur soutien et nous
en remercions merci madame
mesdames les ministres messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues nous en
avons fini avec les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je vais donc suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 16h15 pour le débat sur
la politique européenne de la pêche
la séance est suspendue voilà vous êtes
bien sur public sénat vous avez suivi en
direct les questions d'actualité et nous
eh bien on va refaire la séance dans une
seconde
bienvenue à tous sur public sénat pour
on refait la séance on va débattre
évidemment de ces questions d'actualité
avec nous en plateau pour commenter
une partie de cette actualité en cas une
partie très économique harvey marseille
bonjour bonjour sénateurs udi des
hauts-de-seine on va parler de ce
contexte économique de ces usines qui
ferment
vous avez posé une question au ministre
redressement productif arnaud montebourg
on va d'abord écouté sa réponse
et puis au débat juste après écoute et
petroplus c'est réglé qui avait dit ça
nicolas sarkozy beaucoup de choses
avaient été réglés mais on s'est aperçu
que finalement il ne l'était pas alors
il est vrai que en ce qui nous concerne
nous sommes bien gardé de dire que
c'était réglé car nous connaissions la
difficulté de ce dossier
voilà pour une réponse plutôt franche on
va dire du ministre du redressement
productif avec marseille vous avez parlé
du contexte économique de ces faits
usines qui ferment les unes après les
autres vous avez parlé de l'est de
petroplus il vous a répondu
et ils vous renvoient le bilan de
nicolas sarkozy oui mais enfin il serait
temps que monsieur montebourg et le
gouvernement s'aperçoivent qu'ils
aujourd'hui ils gouvernent c'est à eux
de prendre des mesures c'est pas de
chercher dans le passé des
responsabilités je crois qu'aujourd'hui
avec plus de 1500 pertes d'emplois par
jour eh bien le gouvernement doit
prendre des mesures
il est plus que
mais nécessaire de s'atteler à
l'essentiel je crois qu'après le temps
des promesses vient le temps de l'action
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que tout ce
qui a été fait et dit par monsieur
hollande devant les usines pendant la
campagne présidentielle et bien
aujourd'hui une triste réalité c'est
celle de l'échec et c'est celle du
chômage à 7 ce bilan que vous retenez du
premier la première année du quinquennat
de françois hollande c'est un candidat à
l'époque des usines comme on l'avait
appelée qui finalement n'a pas fait
grand chose pour les employés les
salariés de ces usines qui ferment pas
écouté si j'écoute les syndicalistes
aujourd'hui encore hier l'un d'entre eux
disaient que hollande était pire que
sarkozy c'est vous dire où ils en sont
en termes de valeur donc le cimetière
pourquoi parce que rien n'est fait ou
parce que finalement c'est quelque chose
sur lequel on ne peut pas faire
grand-chose l'état ne peut pas tout
donné c'est cette phrase il est un peu
l'état peut d'ailleurs monsieur
montebourg affirmé à différentes reprise
mais l'état n'a rien fait d'ailleurs il
avait proposé que l'état intervienne et
le premier ministre lui a dit non et le
président de la république a dit non
c'est à dire qu'on a laissé mourir des
entreprises telles que petroplus tels
que florange est aujourd'hui eh bien il
ya une triste réalité c'est le chômage
et c'est pas un constat c'est ce que
vivent les français au quotidien et
pourtant arnaud montebourg vous a égrené
une longue liste de ce qu'il fait
actuellement dans son ministère du
redressement productif
là où il est réussi à sauver des emplois
de 110 par la 250 300 par ci par là
ces choses c'est quelque chose c'est par
rapport à ces feux de choses par rapport
aux milliers d'emplois donner des
chiffres
oui d'accord mais c'est tant mieux
d'ailleurs qu'ils savent quelques
emplois mais y en a 10 par 6 15 par la
sas a fait pas un total je veux dire
quand vous regardez un peugeot par
exemple ce sont des milliers et des
milliers d'emplois et ça va s'accélérer
puisque l'ouverture la fermeture pardon
d'aulnay est prévu plus tôt que prévu
donc
finalement ce sont des milliers
d'emplois alors qu'on est con explique
qu'ici ou là on a réussi à sauver
quelques entreprises tant mieux mais
l'essentiel n'est pas là alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait de ses salariés aujourd'hui
qu'y perdre cet emploi est ce que l'état
doit aux recettes ou sommes tout
particulièrement au reclassement par
exemple il doit accompagner évidemment
cette démarche avec les entreprises de
faire ça oui quand même le pôle emploi
il ya aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le
président de la république nous a
expliqué qu'il avait une boîte à outils
parmi les outils dont il a parlé il y
avait le contrat d'avenir aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que le contrat d'avenir n'est
pas adaptée c'est ce que nous disions
quand nous l'avons voté et donc il est
urgent de réformer le contrat d'avenir
c'est à dire ce que vous voulez en venir
on pourrait élargir ce contrat d'avenir
bien sûr tout à l'heure on en parlait
avec le ministre en charge des relations
avec le parlement à la vie d'alice qui
nous disait eh bien pourquoi pas le
donner sur des emplois du privé c'est
quelque chose que vous souhaitez
toujours bien sûr il faudra gérer c'est
ce qu'ont demandé les parlementaires de
l'opposition lorsqu'on a étudié ce texte
nous n'avons pas été entendus on nous a
expliqué que ce n'est pas souhaitable
et aujourd'hui on nous explique que ça
marche pas et qu'il faut étendre donc
faisons-le ovi n'attendons pas
évidemment aujourd'hui c'est une journée
qui va être marquée par ce 23ème mois
consécutif de hausse du chômage mais
finalement que ce soit la droite ou la
gauche 23 mois c'est pas aux moineaux
finalement ce bilan du chômage c'est
aussi celui de votre ancienne majorité
enfin il ya un gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'est à lui de prendre les affaires en
main c'est à lui de vous répondre dans
la pacifique jédir attendait ils ont été
élus pour agir et ils ont dit on va
faire mieux que les autres
et aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que c'est
pire donc il est urgent que des mesures
soient prises des mesures
d'abord concernant l'emploi on a passé
un temps fou pendant les premiers mois
du quinquennat à abroger les lois des
gouvernements précédents
après on a parlé mariage jusqu'à présent
il serait peut-être temps qu'on s'occupe
de l'emploi
le mariage justement c'est quelque chose
qui revient beaucoup et françois
hollande l'a dit lors de son
intervention mercredi après le conseil
des ministres il a dit on a beaucoup
parlé du mariage c'est vrai mais cette
fois faut parler de l'emploi maintenant
des choses qui intéresse vraiment les
français et sur lequel on a peut-être un
peu plus de solutions à trouver
vous attend donc avec ce qu'a dit
françois hollande il a sifflé la fin de
cet internet si on peut dire et je rends
hommage à sa lucidité mais il eût fallu
que il
elles interviennent plus tôt je veux
dire on a perdu beaucoup de temps et
c'est pas fini puisque et une loi sur la
famille qui va intervenir au mois
d'octobre
que va-t-il en être de la pma on a posé
la question à madame taubira pendant des
jours et des nuits on n'a pas eu de
réponse